son tacle sur la coban ne fonctionne pas
on recule
avec le plan de justin trudeau et la
coût de la vie va augmenter parce qu'il
doit augmenter la taxe la cro bat au
sujet de la taxe carbone un joe
chirurgie trois choses ne fonctionnent
pas il faudra l'augmenter et la taxe
augmente le coût de la vie en gros la
taxe carbone consiste à taxer tout ce
qui produit du co2 à l'exception de
l'agriculture comme ces produits leur
coûte plus cher on change nos habitudes
et on réduit les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mèche
une mesure efficace selon le fonds
monétaire international
la taxe carbone est de loin la meilleure
option pour combattre les changements
climatiques
même certaines grandes pétrolières
albertaines sont en faveur
ensuite faudra-t-il augmenter la taxe
carbone il ya la réponse est oui selon
le directeur parlementaire du budget il
faudra augmenter la taxe carbone si le
canada veut atteindre les objectifs de
l'accord de paix rue
actuellement la taxe s'élève à 20
dollars la tonne de co2 le fédéral
prévoit plafonner le prix à 50 dollars
la tonne en 2022
mais même à 50 dollars la tonne le
canada n'atteint pas ses cibles de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre pour
réaliser les objectifs de paris la taxe
carbone doit passer à 56 dollars la
tonne en 2023 est grippé graduellement
jusqu'à 102 dollars la tonne d'ici 2030
le directeur parlementaire du budget
estime qu'une taxe à 100 dollars la
tonne fera grimper en 2030
le litre d'essence de 23 cents pour
l'instant le gouvernement redistribuent
l'argent de la taxe à une majorité de
canadiens
donc le coût de la vie nous sommes
nécessairement augmenter